we've already brought you a sensational
set of fan theories that could change
how you view your favorite movies and
now we're back to the sequel dear a
popular demand we've brought you five
more crazy but kind of plausible movie
theories this time they're picked by you
straight from the YouTube comments of
our last film theories video The Shining
is Kubrick's apology for staging the
lunar landing break out the tinfoil hats
for this one
in 1969 the United States sent some guys
to the moon it was a pretty big deal and
it was broadcast on TV live around the
world the whole thing was a feat of
Technology and science the likes of
which the world had never seen or was it
a certain group of people believed that
it never happened and that director
Stanley Kubrick staged the whole thing
using cinema magic all of this hinges
upon the shining and young Danny
Torrance his discovery of room 237
supposedly the most evil and heavily
haunted room in the Overlook Hotel at
one point Danny is seen playing with his
toys in a hallway with a unique carpet
design not seen anywhere else in the
Overlook according to this theory this
pattern reflects the shape of an aerial
view of a NASA shuttle launch site Danny
then rises to his feet symbolizing the
Apollo 11 rocket on his sweater lifting
off he proceeds to room 237 which was
originally room 217 in the original
Stephen King novel why the change during
the time of the movies filming earth was
believed to be approximately two hundred
and thirty seven thousand miles from the
moon this distance regularly fluctuates
due to orbit and actually averages out
to about two hundred and thirty eight
thousand 855 miles but who cares
it's a 1980 horror movie there's also a
scene showing Danny and his mother
watching a TV that is visibly not hooked
into anything allegedly this illustrates
that what people watched on the
television during Armstrong's famous
leap was all faked when Danny's father
Jack Torrance investigates room 237
after Danny's hooped he finds a
beautiful naked woman and embraces her
the Jack's dismay the woman transforms
into a decaying older woman is Kubrick
admitting he was happy to take a well
paying job to stage the lunar landing
until he realized what a deceptive thing
it really was or maybe people just need
to get out more there's an entire
documentary dedicated to breaking down a
lot of Kubrick subliminal message
is hidden throughout the shining the
documentaries name room 237 signs was
about demons
remember the whole alien invasion thing
that made up most of the plot of signs
well what if they weren't really aliens
what if they were demons according to a
theory first published on reddit it
could be the case first the alien
invasion results in hundreds of
thousands of people fleeing to temples
churches and other religious buildings
safety are these proper shelters or a
safe place to hide with demons roaming
around second we barely see any alien
technology except for a few lights in
the sky third if these aliens can travel
through space it stands to reason they'd
be smart enough to realize that they
were allergic to water
especially on a planet whose surface is
covered with it the alien we mean demon
at the end of the movie isn't hurt by
h2o alone but because the water is
blessed throughout the movie Mel
Gibson's daughter would regularly get a
full glass of water
sip it put it down and get a new glass
half-full glasses littered the house
when Gibson speaks of the day she was
born he describes a birth his holy even
saying that everyone who saw her that
day thought she was an angel this divine
description transfers to her blessing
every half-filled cup left throughout
the house effectively leaving holy water
all over the place it's not like the
rest of the world chased off an alien
invasion with a bunch of super soakers
Mad Max is death redditor elder Corsair
posted an awesome breakdown of Mad Max
fury road which argues that each of the
three major warlords in the movie
represent one of the Horsemen of the
Apocalypse
warlord of mode and Joe is pestilence
his people are sick dude the nuclear
fallout throughout the land
Joe rules the population by offering
them small amounts of water as if he has
the key to healing them the second
horseman war would be another warlord
the bullet farmer you know the guy
firing wildly into the dark when the
tanker was stuck in the mud
the third Horseman Gamon would be the
warlord known as the people eater
since he's huge and represents the
gluttony of the rich these guys trade
food drink and weaponry among one
another in order to ensure their rule on
this apocalyptic wasteland and the
fourth horseman death that's max think
about it max brings death wherever he
goes across the wasteland and he's
haunted by the death
everyone who wasn't able to say in his
first scene he brings death to a
lizard-like creature by eating death was
on furiosa side and a mission was
ultimately a success
remember when max walks off in the
darkness to take on the bullet farmers
heavily armed vehicle he destroys the
whole thing by himself off screen kills
all the men on board and hauls away all
their stuff you don't even see what
happens he's just assumed that max
killed them all like he always does
it proves max slash death is a constant
inexorable force of nature judge our
Binks is a Sith Lord of all the movie
theories mentioned in response to our
previous video Darth Jar Jar was the
most frequently requested by far as
crazy as it sounds lots of people will
leave the bumbling Gungan we met on
Naboo back in the Phantom Menace is
actually the most powerful Sith Lord in
the universe think about this young
Anakin Skywalker was able to escape just
about every event unscathed due to his
natural aptitude to the force Jar Jar
was also unharmed during the battle
between the Gungans in the Trade
Federation don't let his goofy demeanor
trick you remember Yoda was originally
introduced as just a silly
swamp-dwelling creature on Dagobah
before turning out to be an old Jedi
Master charger can also be seen using a
wave motion that usually accompanies the
Jedi Mind trip during various parts of
Episode one when speaking to important
characters he apparently uses this while
persuading the entire Senate to grant
full control and emergency power to
Supreme Chancellor Palpatine and it
works
this action puts Palpatine in the
perfect position to control everything
and rise to power as Emperor even when
qui-gon gen mentions using the force to
guide them underneath the waters of
Naboo Jar Jar scoffs at the concept
don't forget Palpatine and Jar Jar Binks
of both from the boo and they could have
met each other decades earlier a quag
ons funeral at the end of the Phantom
Menace Jar Jar is standing right beside
Palpatine which starts a recurring theme
of them being seen together in the
beginning of episode 3 you can see Jar
Jar and Palpatine walking close to one
another
Binks also senses Anakin and obi-wan
arrival at the beginning of episode 2 he
approaches the elevator for no reason
and doesn't attempt to open the door he
just waits a second or two knowing that
they are coming but still act surprised
to see them once the door opens in order
to maintain his cover
maybe Jar Jar is almost too obvious
clumsiness wasn't why he was
from the underwater Gundam City and why
they treated him like a threat when he
arrived
maybe supreme leader snoke is a front
and jar-jar binks still continues to
pull the strings of the dark side and
now for one more long time theory that
was actually proven to be true Deckard
is a replicant Ridley Scott's 1982
sci-fi near noir classic Blade Runner is
all about androids these androids also
known as replicants look and think like
humans and possess self-awareness all
that and they're mainly used for
dangerous grunt work on off planet
colonies some of them try to abandon
hazardous work and hide on earth these
escapees are tracked by blade runners a
group of special police operatives who
find and execute errant replicants Blade
Runner Rick Deckard played by Harrison
Ford is responsible for eliminating a
group of rogue replicants it's a quest
that leaves him questioning his duties
as he struggles with the idea that many
of these replicants just want to live
one replicant he meets during his
investigation
Ethan believes she is actually human the
idea that Deckard himself as a replicant
has been debated for years
Harrison Ford claims that he was playing
a human character according to BBC News
Ford mentioned that he and the director
had talks about Deckard being a replica
and they both agreed that he was a human
during filming but in subsequent
interviews over the years Ridley Scott
has said otherwise
he's a replica perhaps Scott lied to
Ford to make his performance much more
convincing thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know if
there are any more fan theories you'd
like to see explored